بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين
والصلاه والسلام على رسوله الكريم وعلى
اله واصحابه اجمعين
واشهد ان لا اله الا الله
واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله
اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على نبينا محمد وعلى
اله واصح اصحابه اجمعين
اما بعد
فالدرس موصول وقراءه موص وقراءتنا موصوله
لكتاب رياض الصالحين
من كلام سيد المرسلين
للحافظ الفقيه المحدث
ابي زكريا يحيى بن شرف النووي
رحمه الله تعالى في الباب الاول
وهو باب الاخلاص واحضار النيه
في جميع الاعمال والاقوال
والاحوال
البارزه والخفيه
كرياض
الصالحين
الحافظ النووي رحمه
‏sincerity
andent
in
all acts of worship whether they be
action they be
they be statements they be states of
being
belief actions of the heart etc and so
the chapter is more than merely
‏and intend by sincerity here
that
any actship
anything
in
dra to
be sin
only forake الله سبحانه وتالى
two
small
forحه
وى
اسلام لا اله الا الله محمد رسول الله
محمد
الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
لا اله الا
الله
محمد رسول الله
صلى الله عليه
‏inovation
prop صلى الله عليه وسلم not did not did
not
allow
it cann beigible for acceptance
and so
sincerity
is one of those
‏important
because
this is
the
act of worship and I'm speaking about
that the prophets and messengers
came to most
actively teach us because the prophets
and messengers again came to teach
لا اله الا الله محمد رسول الله
الله
ير
بن عبد الله الانصاري
رضي الله عنه
جابر انس رضي الله عنهما
صلى الله عليه
‏am
unable
because of
the
‏any
up to
have to go et whatever theuseason was
they int
of joining the propon
‏use
couldate
could
prop صلى الله عليه
[Silence]
جابر
ان بالمدينه لرجالا ما سرتم مسيرا ولا
قطعتم مواديا
الا كانوا معكم حبسهم المرض
فنستفيد من هذه اللفظه ما سرتم مسيرا ولا
قطعتم واديا
يعني
لهم الاجر جمله وتفصيلا
فلهم الاجر
تاما
كانما كانوا معهم
رضي الله عنه
صلى الله عليه
‏are back
you all have not taken crossed
they
وفي
الا شركوكم الاجر
ف في اللفظه الاولى الا كانوا معكم كانوا
معهم حسا لا كانوا معهم شرعا هذه تسمى عند
العلماء بالحقيقه الشرعيه كانوا معهم شرعا
وان لم يكونوا معهم حسا
هذه الحقيقه الشرعيه مهم اعتبارها وهي
المعتبره في حكم حكم الله سبحانه وتعالى
الله عز وجل ذكر في سوره النور
ان الذي لم ياتي باربعه شهداء
يشهدون فاولئك عند الله هم الكاذبون
طيب ممكن يكونوا صادقين عرفا لكن شرعا هم
كاذبون هذه تسمى بالحقيقه الشرعيه
so we have the prophet صلى الله عليه
وسلم
الله سبحانه وتعالى
صلى الله عليه وسلم
الا شركوكم في الاجر
جمله وتفصيلا ليس فقط
على النيه ليسوا ماجورين على نياتهم فقط
بل ماجورون على نياتهم
وعلى العمل الذي حال
قدر الله سبحانه وتعالى حال المرض حال
العذر
بينهم وبينه
صلى الله عليه وسلم انذا
‏with
another
البخاري رحمه الله
انس رضي الله
صلى الله عليه وسلم
تبوك
صلى الله عليه وسلم ان اقواما خلفنا
بالمدينه
ما سلكنا شعبا ولا واديا الا وهم معنا
حبسهم العذر يعني ليس فقط المرض بل قد
يكون الفقر حبسهم
قله الظهر
قله السلاح قله الطعام حبسهم العذر العذر
الشرعي والعذر الحسي والا فبالنيه
هم معنا
صلى الله عليه
‏take
prysically
being here with us was valid excuse so
what do we understand from this we
understand from this the seriousness of
the intention and that the intention
trumps whateverysically happens at
points meaning that when we are judg
وى
all
make anything will be based on our
intentions behind
and if a persons
out to do something good and then is
unable to complete it while trying to
complete it at his best this person will
have it
‏and his consistent doing he always
praying at always prays he always this
always monday or thursday he always
gives charity this amount every week or
month or what have you and then becomes
ill becomes po whatever it is becomes
old and is unable to do these
الله ان سوره التين
الا الذين امنوا وعملوا الصالحات فلهم اجر
غير ممنون غير ممنون اي غير مقطوع
غير منتهن فكما انه حال بينهم وبين الموت
اعماله التي كانوا يعملونها في حياتهم
فكذلك في الجنه يرزقون ابدا وهذا الرزق
غير منقطع عنهم
لان الله تعالى يكتب ما نقدم واثارنا
ويكتب سعينا نسال الله سبحانه وتعالى بمنه
وكرمه وجوده ان يعلمنا ما ينفعنا وان
ينفعنا بما علمنا
وان يرزقنا حسن النيه والختام الحسن والله
اعلم وصلى الله وسلم على نبينا محمد وعلى
اله واصحابه اجمعين والحمد لله